Prince's ex-wife Manuela Tess Shalini is  paying tribute to the late artist by  giving back the 39 year old told ET she  is quote heartbroken beyond words after  hearing the news of the legendary  artists death on Thursday quote Prince  and I had a magical journey together and  I loved him immensely I knew him as a  husband friend and fierce philanthropist  philanthropy brought us together and it  was Prince that encouraged me to start  my own charity over 10 years ago the two  met in 2001 when Manuela was working for  his charity they were married that same  year and divorced amicably in 2006 she  told us she recently reached out to  Prince to tell him of her latest project  quote I just reached out to Prince a few  days ago to let him know that I was  building a school in his honor my heart  aches that the school will now be built  in his memory